bonjour et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation ce matin sur rtl france à
leur première question la libye at elle
un espoir de trouver une stabilité
politique et d'ouvrir un chemin vers la
démocratie
et ceci en commun a déclaré avec
nathalie et plongée dans le chaos
la crise libyenne je répète toujours mon
style prises d'ordre structurel c'est
pas une crise politique conjoncturelle
de passage mais structurel qu'est ce
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
l'otan en 2011 a dit à la fois le
gouvernement le régime et l'état l'état
ça veut dire sonar mais c'était la
colonne vertébrale et sa police
nationale en l'état alors on a le droit
de monopole de la violence légitime
armées disaient max weber en libye
cet état n existe plus de piles depuis
il y à des micro états qui sont armés
je cite à titre d'exemple bernard ouest
doit tripoli les milices islamistes toit
ou le conseil militaire de misrata
routaboul reçu de l'armée nationale ne
dirigeait pas le manifeste à l'est
plusieurs protagonistes armés donc c'est
un problème d'ordre structurel
c'est vrai sur le pape il ya toujours
des solutions magiques
au plan théorique de la crise libyenne
même le gouvernement de monsieur bah et
deux au discours devant le parlement à
tobrouk
au plan théorique c'est excellent mais
la réalité est une autre chose la
réalité libyenne et que toutes ces
milices armées sont toujours armés et
qu'il va y va parmi les milices en libye
kial la puissance militaire afin de
désarmer tout ces milices et aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui aussi des seigneurs de
guerre qui sont enrichis de cette guerre
et qui ont profité tirer profit de cette
guerre ajoutons à tout cela évidemment
les ingérences étrangères
il voit en libye avec des pancartes ou
un gâteau à partager donc donc les
ingérences étrangères aussi compliquer
la tâche des libyens alors justement on
sait que c'est
dix années d'affrontements dans le pays
ont été marqués par les ingérences
étrangères aujourd'hui quelle est la
position des différentes parties
libyennes que vous venez de citer quant
à ces arbres intervention extérieure
les islamistes qui ont été soutenues par
l'auto 2011
n'oublions pas le temps armes et les
frères musulmans à tripoli et même la
branche des cas il a dirigé par hakim
belhaj
il était alors vous entends les
islamistes contre kadhafi n'oublions pas
tout cela aujourd'hui les islamistes de
tout genre sont soutenus financièrement
par le qatar par la turquie la turquie
aussi militairement qui est un pilier un
pilier de l'otan et à l'estonie l'armée
nationale libyenne dirigée par les
marcheurs et soutenu par l'egypte et les
émirats arabes unis donc il ya dix ans
gérant ses projets la libye et la
tunisie ou l'algérie
ils ont une position positive ça veut
dire la même distance face aux
protagonistes les biens c'est pour cette
raison que monsieur quand il a été entre
hippolyte y est remonté hier
pourquoi parce que il est dans une
position objective
or les autres sont les autres gérance
vise la richesse de la libye le pétrole
de la libye ne s'est pas associée à rien
alors on sait que aujourd'hui au bout de
dix ans l'économie
bienne est complètement sinistré la
situation humanitaire est également la
catastrophique de quel type d' aide
extérieure la libye at elle besoin
aujourd'hui puisque le problème est donc
consentir elle il faut une solution
aussi d'ordre structurel c'est
construire l'état libyen entremont d'y
construire une armée nationale libyenne
il n'a police nationale libyenne
homogène et crise des pays de l'est à
l'ouest et du nord au sud
mais qu'il va faire ça l'onu les casques
bleus
les libyens eux mêmes les ingérences
étrangères la tâche est très très
difficile moi j'ai bien entendu le
discours de mme chirac ami de biba à
terme au lock devant le parlement disais
ce sera un miracle si on arrive à
construire l'iss
reconstruire les institutions libyennes
le dire par les institutions deviennent
à leur tête l'armée nationale et la
police nationale ça sera vraiment un
miracle lui même jamais demain dans son
discours à vous qu'il y à des ingérences
étrangères qui vont se tenir compte
parce qu'ils sont tellement puissantes
et forte dans dans les affaires des
libyens la grande problématique de lui
évidemment et ses partis politiques sont
au costaud rue après 2011 et le la
négligence que là ça suffit les
bienvenus c'est une société tribale
les américains toujours propose la
solution magique c'est allé tenir des
élections les urnes
et c'est ça la démocratie or la
démocratie c'est autre chose c'est une
culture politique
les libyens ont voté en 2000 rejoint
les islamistes paulino par accepter les
résultats c'est que la rue deux
parlements un parlement très polis et un
autre art book et le pays divisé en deux
donc ce ne sont pas les élections de
décembre tu peux venir qui vont résoudre
la crise libyenne qui frise torgau
structurelle parce que steam prise
d'état la grande problématique est la
grande question comment construire les
pelles et bien nouveau merci beaucoup en
tout cas réac seddaoui d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
expert du monde arabe et directeur du
centre arabe de recherches d'analystes
politiques et sociales à genève en
suisse